ouverte et accessible gratuitement pour
tous depuis le 19 mai et jusqu'au 30
juin l'exposition brun d'arre est le
fruit d'une collaboration entre les deux
sociétés est in business et brun de
france un roulement tous les quinze
jours permettra à une trentaine
d'artistes dit être exposée sur six
semaines on va représenter 33 artistes
donc trois ans 33 artistes qui vont
défiler
on a même bien appeler ça un défilé
d'art puisque sur trois sessions de 15
jours chacune
onze artistes sur chaque session va
pouvoir voilà montrer leur présenter
leur travail
au programme peinture sculpture
photographie les artistes seront
présents et vont pouvoir en semaine ou
le week-end venir à la rencontre des
visiteurs
c'est ça que j'aime dans les arts les
autres c'est que moi je les ai faites
mais chaque personne qui les regardent
va se les approprier et va s'imaginer ce
qu'il a envie en fonction de son vécu en
fonction de ses émotions
je pense que ça va donner un vrai élan
de liberté à tout le monde aux artistes
aux visiteurs et danser une initiative
qu'on peut vraiment que saluer cette
exposition sera mise au profit du
service pédiatrique de l'hôpital mignot
l'une des artistes que je représente
leur simoneau nous apprennent jolie
structure et nous allons faire une
oeuvre collaborative
nous vendrons des morceaux de ruban que
les gens pourront déposer sur cette
structure est avec cet argent décolleté
récolté nous irons ré investir dans du
matériel d'art supplémentaires auprès de
nos partenaires pour tout le monde soit
gagnant
et on offrira tout ça au service
pédiatrie au mois de juillet plusieurs
événements vont être organisées comme
des vernissages chaque vendredi de début
de session des nocturnes dès que le
protocole sanitaire le permettra ou
encore trois soirées dégustation vins et
fromages